you know all you have to know and that
is a new Tarantino films out you know
that shit's a party the hateful eight
so the hateful eight is the eighth film
written and directed by Quentin
Tarantino and keeping it vague because
it's supposed to be vague everything I
heard about this movie was vague the
trailer was vague so I was going to this
movie with vague information it starts
out with Kurt Russell he's a bounty
hunter he comes across samuel l.jackson
he's another bounty hunter Kurt
Russell's toting Jennifer Jason Leigh
because he's taking her to the hangman
to hang but a blizzard closes in so now
they're in this cabin with other people
there's eight of them all and all but
something is amiss there is a culprit
involved so now it's kind of a mystery
it's kind of a whodunit in Tarantino
fashion this is as if Quentin Tarantino
directed a very Tarantino West Western
version of clue all the while with
Quentin Tarantino s characters and
Quentin Tarantino s dialogue between
said characters now I will say if you
can rest on the laurels of great
dialogue great characters alone they I
found your cup of tea there you go you
are welcome
it's the hateful eight samuel l.jackson
crushes it in this movie was great to
see him in the forefront of a Tarantino
movie again Kurt Russell also Kurt
Russell is another great performance in
this movie Jennifer Jason Leigh she was
even good I mean she was even good as in
she's the prisoner she's not supposed to
be one of the standouts but she really
was in this movie but also you have
Bruce Dern there's one scene in
particular Bruce Dern just looks
horrified I'm like I feel bad for Bruce
Dern he's a little old guy in his little
charity looks freaked out you just want
to pat him on the head I can go on and
on but really everyone in this movie
does a great job and I've noticed that
in Tarantino movies just he always pulls
great performances from actors I'm
constantly surprised that Tarantino can
just hold people because two people are
talking I mean if pulp fiction taught us
anything it's that Tarantino can hold
your interest while two people are
talking in a diner and that's what this
movie was like a lot of interesting
dialogue tension building dialogue but
again it's a whodunit so you got to
figure it out so it makes attention just
a little more Tarantino shot this thing
in seventy millimeter he makes it look
and feel like yeah I mean the overture
is going in the beginning of the movie
like they did back in the day like the
Golden Age of cinema and you even see
the picture kind of bobbing which
sprocket bobbing you're like oh wow it's
not like digital that's like film and
Tarantino's love for film shine
the format and canvas that he displays
this movie on every other director out
there is running at the first chance to
film their new film in digital 3d
Tarantino's filming the hateful eight in
the format that directors used five
decades ago that's awesome that's just
love and you can't deny that in this
movie Quentin Tarantino doesn't just set
up a movie his movies are experiences
and experience from the overture at the
beginning to the intermission in the
middle of this movie the three hour
runtime it just feels like you are five
decades in the past a speaking of the
overture holy [ __ ] I got to talk about
the music in this movie yeah it's
amazing it's like one of those from the
overture at the beginning I was like I
love this song
I want to hear this song every day it's
this eerie ass tension building music I
challenge you eat breakfast with your
family in your suburbs with your white
picket fence with your wonderful you the
wife and the dad and the kids sit around
eat your Cheerios listening to this
music you will not help but you can't
help but just get the shifty eyes like
yeah which one of you did it it's just
in the notes man there's something about
I love this music this movie isn't
without his flaw I say flaw because it's
really one flaw but it was kind of a
compromising flaw and that is you have
eight suspects in this movie so you want
to kind of like narrow it down our eyes
not that person it's not that person and
you narrow it down a little bit and then
all of a sudden add a point in the movie
the beans are just spilled it's like all
right and narrow down I was like oh well
I was having fun with that
I guess that parts over now that part
being everything this movie has been
built around so really the movie is over
and we're just in the last act now so
now we're going to have some Tarantino
carnage and I get we were going to get
to the Tarantino carnage I just didn't
think that everything was just going to
be revealed so soon after you started
crossing people off the list and that
kind of bummed me out a movie like this
is going to greatly depend on the payoff
the revelation how it's done the fun
you're having good oh my gosh it's not
that person that could have been that
person who that person was over there
when something happened over there so it
couldn't have in that person I like
things like that the last I would have
liked that to last throughout the movie
but guys in the end the hateful eight
was a unique experience among this
cinematic experiences I have had in 2015
I was talking about this movie with my
friends I was like yeah I liked it I
don't know that I liked it as much as
Kill Bill or pulp fiction those
Tarantino films I have seen over and
over and over and over again but I've
spent the last few hours really thinking
about this movie and in the end it is a
great movie great performances great
acting great cinematic
perience great dialogue great mystery I
truly did love the hateful eight the
ones again Tarantino has delivered us a
movie with lines and dialogue and quotes
that are going to be used in film
schools around the world when teachers
are like alright get your two bits of
dialogue day oh god it's another
Tarantino move you're doing Tarantino
movie again of course you are because
the hateful eight is awesome tacular
alright guys so the hateful eight have
you seen it what did you think about it
or what's your favorite Quentin
Tarantino movie of all time thus far
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more